what's up guys
bang bang it's lunch money time well
while she's trying to get rich for us
let's just trying to get our lunch money
right
i'm here with the beautiful intelligent
pelina
i'm tired i was up till three o'clock in
the morning i'm just gonna throw that
out there
right now don't forget that lunch money
is not sponsored by block five
go get an interest bearing account you
can earn up to eight point six percent
apy
in that interest bearing account there's
chaos in the world you're not going to
find 8.6
anywhere else go get a block fi account
you can also buy and sell crypto you can
deposit crypto and take out a us dollar
loan
against that crypto collateral block fi
is awesome i'm an investor i sit on the
board i'm a user i'm happy you'll be
happy go get a blockfly account block
five.com
pomp what were you doing until 3am
i was watching the election wild that is
our first topic
the never ending election it's still
going on
if you want to oh i'm wearing a georgia
sweatshirt george is divided right now
it feels like the whole world is kind of
divided but yeah so it's still going on
we don't know who the president is but
we will probably soon i'm only going to
say two things
okay one the polling experts are idiots
well they try their best maybe but like
that whole industry is broken i tweeted
it last night they're basically like
meteorologists
like the meteorologist it's going rain
today it doesn't rain i'm like okay well
how do you keep being wrong and keep
your job
uh and i understand it's hard i
understand there's probability i get it
but uh you know you had four years to
figure out the polling situation and
that was completely wrong
second is there's a lot of people
surprised
there's democrats that are surprised
there's republicans that are surprised
and what i think that this is showing is
that
we need more listening we need more
collaboration and we need less division
in this country
so the fact that the democratic side
of our country is yelling and screaming
that our president is racist
our current president is racist but 70
percent
of latino voters in a certain area
are voting for them both can be true
agreed but just
those two things don't follow the same
narrative
secondly on the republican side there
was
a number of narratives that got
completely violated last night right
there's there's
states and counties that have
historically been republican
that flipped and so what ends up
occurring is just
we need people working together we need
more collaboration
we need much more unity and we need to
remember
we're all on the same team that's all
this is about
we're on the same team i read i read uh
this article that basically
it was a survey or a poll and it asked
americans about all the hot button
issues and actually the majority of
people
like agreed with each other and versus
where you know we think like the one
side is this and one's
like people think the majority of
americans think
racism is bad and there's something to
do we have to do something about it
that's that's like a thing but if you
only watch the news you think we are so
divided and nobody believes the same
thing
so my message is very simple
in this country we need to work together
we need to remember we're on the same
team we have to understand that we may
have different opinions
as to how to get to those solutions and
that's okay
but by being more collaborative by
listening to each other by working
together
we're more likely to get there or more
likely to live in a safe
prosperous happy society instead of just
pulling the rope to our side
yeah rather than just constantly being
divided having the mainstream media be
so divisive in their coverage
right all of these things it's
everyone's responsibility whether you're
an individual
private citizen whether you're a member
of the mainstream media whether you're
part of the new media
or whether you're a politician it is
everyone's responsibility
we need to work together not argue with
each other not be so divisive
and what you're going to find is my
prediction
is that we are going to have a violent
return to extreme moderation
i really hope so right now we have a
country
where the people who are being rewarded
are at the extreme ends of
either political party so if you are
hardcore conservative
or you are hardcore liberal you're being
rewarded right now
there's an entire generation of people
and i'm one of them who's growing up
saying this is stupid why are you guys
fighting like this
let's use some common sense let's work
together let's find solutions that are
in the middle
because the best compromises the best
deals are always when two people walk
away from the table
wishing for a little bit more it becomes
less of an argument and more of a
negotiation
of course and so it's just collaboration
that's what we need in this country
we need people working together not
fighting each other
and it's every single person's
responsibility and that's all i'm going
to say
is who cares who wins the election
that's going to be true regardless
and whoever ends up being the president
should be
the president and govern everyone let's
go both sides
not just their side both sides of course
all sides
um by the way when sometimes when we
disagree on something we have to remind
each other okay we're on the same team
let's solve it instead of just
i want it my way and you i always win
though okay
so jp morgan chase ceo jamie dimon told
employees that they must have faith in
the us election process and patience to
await a final determination
while strong opinions and tremendous
passion characterize this us election it
is the responsibility of each of us to
respect the democratic process
and ultimately the outcome diamond said
wednesday in a memo to all
u.s employees with the subject line u.s
election update
so if you're the ceo of one of these big
banks or companies or whatever
how do you deal with something like this
when all your people might be upset one
way or another
what you really should do is what
they've done for decades and decades and
decades
which is you keep politics out of the
workplace
right the problem is that we live in a
society today
where people want to work in a place
that they feel
like embodies their values right so if
you were a pure capitalist
just um optimizing for how do we
build as profitable company as possible
you'd keep politics out
obviously the world's not black and
white and so you have humans working
there those humans have desires they
have interests they have political
leanings things like that
so it's a it's a tough uh thing to kind
of balance and look the message
i think is pretty non-controversial of
let the cards fall where they're
gonna fall and then whoever the
president is gonna be the president
it's not like that seems pretty common
sense to me right
uh and by the way if there's disputes or
controversies or whatever
they'll go to court and the court system
will figure it out
like i'm not a judge i don't know what
this all the rules are they'll figure it
out
right and when they figure it out then
they'll tell us okay here's who the
president is and we'll move forward
let's go okay
on tuesday tesla ceo elon musk tweeted
that his electric car company had been
about a month away from bankruptcy in
recent years
when it was still figuring out how to
mass produce the model 3 electric
siddha sedan sedan sedan um not sedan
sedan so musk said the closest we got
was about a month the model 3 ramp was
extreme stress and pain for a long time
from mid-2017 to mid-2019 production
and logistics hell so i mean he tweeted
this at somebody's random question
i i like that he's transparent but i
feel like if
this was happening now he wouldn't be
this open about it
yeah i mean look if it didn't work he
probably wouldn't be talking about it
and also i think he enjoys kind of the
the hero's journey a little bit right he
enjoys people knowing hey we almost went
bankrupt
because it kind of feeds into the uh
elon narrative
by the way if they if if that's true and
all accounts say that it is
uh it's pretty crazy right that that
that business
one month or one month yeah spacex he
was one
failed rocket launch away uh from it
failing so
it's pretty it's pretty nuts at how much
uh risk that guy has taken
uh and obviously it's worked out and
it's been rewarded
waymo the self-driving company of
google's parent company alphabet
has suspended itself driving operations
in san francisco as businesses and
cities
brace for potential unrest following the
presidential election
why would they do that they just don't
they they feel like they the waymo can't
handle protests and many people being in
the street
i mean there might be a technology
component to it for sure
uh i think just generally people are
saying you know whether it's small
businesses in new york city whether it's
self-driving cars or whatever people are
just saying hey there's uncertainty
here uh and we want to reduce our risk
and what's the best way to reduce our
risk is to
stop right or pause or slow down or do
whatever
um and so it seems like that's what
they're doing yep
makes sense i mean like what what's the
advantage right it's like a risk reward
okay cool we keep our service going for
48 hours
uh or we basically stop it for 48 hours
we
make sure there's no incidents and then
we kind of just pick it back up you know
three days from now
like yep risk reward it says you would
probably want to slow down
so the u.s dollar has been weak for most
of donald trump's presidency tax cuts a
bigger deficit and several interest rate
cuts from the federal reserve have
pushed the greenback
lower but even if trump loses to joe
biden the dollar may not dramatically
rebound
anytime soon do you believe this
yeah i'm not a um i know some people
think that
the macro economy changes a lot wow i
just yawned
you see that 3 a.m uh they think that
the macro economy changes a lot based on
who the president is
i'm actually more of a believer that
like the president
can have an impact just not a severe
impact on a lot of that stuff
sure are there policy changes yes of
course um but like the federal reserve
is going to target a plus two percent uh
inflation target regardless of if it's
trump or biden in office
right and so i think that like are there
things around like the stimulus package
sure but like whether the republicans
get a 1.8 trillion dollar package or the
democrats get their 2.2 trillion dollars
we're still gonna get about two uh
trillion dollars in the stimulus package
so i just think that the precedent
doesn't necessarily matter
as much uh as people like to think when
it comes to the macro economy
yup all right ready yeah walmart has
ended its effort to use roving robots
and store aisles to keep track of its
inventory
reversing a year's long push to automate
the task with the machines
after finding during the chronovirus
pandemic that humans
can help get similar results
sometimes simpler is just as useful yeah
i mean look it's fine it probably also
costs a lot of money to do the robots
more than the humans isn't the whole
point that the robots would cost less
than the human
labor well it depends right so
if you've got to pay you know let's say
that the technology today i'll make up
numbers is half a billion a half a
million dollars per robot
right i don't know if that's true let's
just say uh and in five years it's gonna
be fifty thousand dollars per robot just
with the advancement technology
right it'll get better over time but i
just think it's ironic that they talked
about these robots for so long now
they're
testing humans humans are good
they can do it all right what else
that's it oh wait hold on i have one
more topic
we have four minutes what uh well i
don't know what the timer says but i
have four minutes
uh there was a big big update yesterday
that i need to address oh god the state
of oregon had
a ballot and on that ballot was a um
i don't know like a legislation that the
voters voted on
and they chose to decriminalize
heroin meth cocaine psychedelics etc
this is going to be a
very interesting experiment there are
some
academic papers that suggest by
decriminalizing all of this
drug use actually will go down something
to me
and supposedly from what i've read so
far oregon is taking some of the funds
and they're going to actually put it
into addiction centers and be more about
rehabilitation rather than
criminalization
so it's very interesting we'll see if it
works or not i'm going to read some more
on it maybe we'll do a whole
series uh on this but the reason why i
want to bring it up is not because i
think that
uh decriminalizing heroin meth and
cocaine is interesting
uh the decriminalization or more so the
legalization
of uh psychedelics is going to be a
massive business uh i feel like yeah
it's really trying to be a
big business with micro dosing and all
that stuff well everyone has been
interested
in marijuana and obviously that's going
to be a big business already is a big
business
but psychedelics i think people uh who
have not looked at that yet
go check it out there are some
very very serious kind of studies and
things that show just material impact
whether it's around depression
ptsd you know all these different things
uh and so organ kind of being the first
state to take a step on the psychedelic
uh training that's interesting is uh
it's gonna be a pretty big step
i think when we look back just had to
bring that up since it wasn't a topic
okay uh joke time all right hit us
i married my wife for her looks
[Laughter]
just not the ones she's been giving me
lately
that wasn't funny so funny i thought
that i thought the joke was just i
married my wife for her looks
see you didn't get it oh no i got it i
just chose to ignore you
and not participate in your little
stupid joke
i think you look beautiful don't worry
about it all right guys because i am
beautiful that's it for lunch money
today
i'm the most i'm going to try to get a
nap or sleep look at anything
more beautiful ever again go on
i'll talk to you guys tomorrow bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind paulina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends